Thinking with, thinking, thinking with, thinking, thinking with, thinking, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're going to feast on this one.
Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought.
That's what it is, that's what it is, that's what it is.
The internal structure of book.
As soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from the subject.
Thinking with, thinking, thinking, thinking with, thinking with.
To The Gay Science, we're focusing on the back third of, of Book Three.
And Nate, you said that you were sort of really taken by the, the short aphorisms toward the end.
Yeah.
So 217 is like, is cause and effect.
Before the effect, one believes in different causes than one does afterward.
And one like that, you know, because Nietzsche and Deleuze especially is all about effects without causes, essentially.
But even before you get to that, it's a reconceptualization of that entire process.
So like every time you, basically when you, like think about your own life, when you, when you think of a cause for like an emotional state.
Let's say you were anxious for a period of time.
Like I, I was anxious during the transition period from college to grad school.
First of all, for obvious reasons, cause it's transitional, but also because I didn't realize that I was, I didn't know at the time that I was trapped in a relationship.
Um, so it wasn't until like two years, three years afterwards that I was able to attribute the cause.
And even now, even as I'm trying to do that, I'm sure there were other nuances to that cause.
So it's always a process of like reifying, um, that logic, I think.
It also speaks to the activity of attributing causes to effects as well.
That it's not reflective and therefore subject to it being true or false.
Is it the correct diagnosis?
It's not given.
The cause isn't given.
It always, the cause is changing.
Well, it's not just that the cause is changing.
It's also that then attributing the cause to the effect, this is, is itself an active intervention that then becomes an antigen in the entire configuration.
And I mean, this is, this really coordinates a lot with, you know, like go to 205 and this is in many ways, you know, sort of like the launching point of say like the genealogy morality.
So this is on need, um, need is taken to be the cause why something came to be.
And reality is often merely an effect of which has come to be.
And, you know, this is so much of like, you know, the, the, this is the basic genealogical error for Nietzsche is to presume that something came about because there was a need for it.
And just the way that he reverses that relationship is things come about because of the expression of abundance of force, expression of force.
And then the, then we have to think about the attribution of a, of a need or the attribution of a cause to an effect as itself, a, um, an expression of force, an expression of power, expression of will, and not simply the reflection or the realization of a prior state of being.
It is its own intervention.
I think that kind of goes to what you were saying with, um, that sense of effects without, effects without causes.
That's one way of saying it.
The other way is to say it is that the, in, in a profound, important sense, the attribution of a cause to an effect is it's, uh, is, is only added later, but not simply superfluously or incorrectly, but importantly, as its own line of intervention.
And, and, and adds its own difference, it becomes its own, um, or adds its own sort of differential power to the, to the equation, altering it.
Right.
Can, can I ask us for a second to take a step back?
Yeah.
Um, because this is, this is something for me that I have, like, I'm, I'm just sort of thinking through.
So, so, but, but I've been aware of myself in the past, like when we deal with, these aphorisms are different than most Nietzsche aphorisms in the sense that they're the, they are, I think Boo Boo used the word pithy, right?
Like these pithy one liner things.
They're not, um, um, I don't know.
They're, they're, they're, they're not investigations in the same way that many of the aphorisms feel like they're investigations.
They are maxims almost, um, and, and other books have these moments, right?
Like, have moments of maxims in this, and it, and it just, you know, you get this string of 20 pages that is different than the previous 20 or the previous hundred pages.
Right.
Um, and it's not just a question of the length.
It is partly a question of the length, you know, where like the other ones are a page or so.
And these are all like one or two sentences, like boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
And I have in the past always had the tendency to just really skim these things.
Yeah, me too.
Like, and not read them with the, and just like wait till I get to the ones where it's like, okay, this is going to be something meaty.
Um, and because it feels to me as if when I read these, these pithy aphorisms, like, like what we just did right there, we did a lot of fucking work on us.
It's, you know, a lot of thinking that we attributed, it, it's, it's almost like the, the pithy ones demand us to invent what they will have been about.
That is reassigning the cause, you know, you know, um, but it's a different kind of labor and it's a different kind of experience in reading.
And I've always found myself, including today, now today, partly because, you know, there was a time limit or whatever else, but I found myself skimming them and then became aware of that.
I was skimming them and became aware that I usually do skim them, even when I'm just reading it on my own, not in a hurry for anything.
And I'm wondering if you guys have that, had that where like very rare, like if I'm reading one of those other, you know, page ish, three quarter page, whatever aphorisms, I sit with it while I'm reading it.
Like, and I don't do that with these, with these, I, I don't sit with them.
I don't know why it is.
I don't know if it's simply the length or it's because there's so many in a row or that maybe they seem almost disposable because there's so many of them in a row.
Like, I don't know, I don't know what you guys were thinking about that, but I'd like to, I'd like to sit with them a little bit more, but it seems harder to do, I guess.
I, I think it's, I find the same thing with me.
I tend to skim through them and it's only, it requires a certain force of will to sit down and try to, to ruminate on them a little bit.
I think partially it's just the genre of the maxim that, you know, that the, the, say like the, the fable and the maxim are so, so sort of installed as, um, as a genre of our literary moralistic worlds that they, you know, it just, they, they, they feel like they're obvious.
And, and, and, um, uh, uh, run very well, um, uh, worn grooves.
And so, but these don't, these run very sort of counter to, to the groove.
So like, I mean, within the sort of rhetorical, um, structural, uh, um, genre of the maxim, they feel very, very familiar and therefore invite a certain kind of speed.
But because they run so counter, um, to, you know, the typical body of maxims that we run into, you know, they shouldn't make us, I think, stop a little bit more.
Yeah.
I think, uh, before we get into it, I'll just express my, uh, orientation towards them really quick.
Cause I think that when I was prepping for this podcast, I was attempting to do a little bit of double duty for, cause I also have class tomorrow.
So I was like, how can I at least cut and paste a few of these?
And I think the smaller ones, of course, are going to be a little bit more accessible for my students.
I'm not going to require them to read like a majority of this text.
And so I like talking about the writing process and some of these, I think have some insight onto that process.
Now, like you were saying, John, I have to do most of that work, but I like to, for teaching, I, I, that seems to be my tendency recently is
take little chunks, little excerpts, little samples of texts.
And then I do all of that labor to, to make it relevant for the class.
Um, and so I don't know, I think it invites a certain type of, uh, disposition towards the text.
But I, I also agree that in general, if I wasn't, if I weren't teaching tomorrow, I think I probably would have skimmed.
But one of the reasons that you slow down isn't just the teaching, but I'm going to guess that you're, you're used.
I used some shorter aphorisms from Nietzsche as writing prompts and, you know, writing through it really forces you to slow down.
And I've always been actually pretty shocked because that first one I did them, I wasn't expecting much engagement, but just because that writing slows you down and allows the sort of the oddity of some of these things to hit students, then they just produce voluminously.
And just sort of like to speak to our, um, what, you know, at first, John, when you mentioned our need to sort of bring, do a lot more work, I was thinking of the sort of the, um, the, um, uh, poetica, homo poetica line.
But I'm going to go to a different one instead to try to stick with these shorter ones.
This is 192, the good-natured.
What distinguishes those good-natured people whose faces radiate goodwill from the rest?
They feel well in the presence of another person and quickly fall in love with him.
Consequently, they wish him well.
And their first judgment is I like him in such people.
There is the following succession.
The wish to appropriate.
They do not scruple much over the worth of the other person.
Quick appropriation, delight in possession, and action for the benefit of the person possessed.
I mean, I think we can think of these aphorisms as that sort of, that, that person in which to take delight in and to appropriate and to express through.
That it creates that sort of active, reactive relationship through which, you know, will is expressed and altered and affected and affects and is affected by.
Yeah, and even the one right below it, like, this is a little bit different from what you were just saying.
But it's not that there are like secrets contained within the aphorism that you have to unravel.
That would be kind of the hermeneutic approach.
But like with this one on Kant, basically that pithy thing on Kant is diagnosing the entire Kantian project.
Like, you know, so you could, you could do the work, you could have an entire essay, a book on that aphorism.
I thought the exact same thing.
So many of these things, they just feel like such incredibly distilled, pithy, but distilled and on target and smart takes that would, would require, you know, pages, articles, books.
Well, let's go to movies to sort of unravel because, you know, 195, you know, this is laughable.
Look, look, he is running away from people, but they follow him because he is running ahead of them.
That is how much they are heard.
And I just instantly thought of Monty Python's Life of Brian.
It's like, that was an entire movie that simply, that dramatizes, you know, that, those two and a half lines that, that Nietzsche writes.
The entire movie is that.
It's so, it's so funny.
Just the couple of examples that you guys have picked, when we read them, I hear Kafka's short story, like Kafka's parables.
You know, like, and Kafka would not, I mean, he is making like a declarative philosophical point.
Kafka would have the character running ahead and people chasing behind, like he would have the actual dramatize it.
But it just reads so much like these Kafkaesque moments of, of different ways, different ways of living, like different, different styles of life encountering one another.
And that diagnostic, I mean, that's, for me, like, what's the one about the different, the changing of color, the changing color?
That one, I love that one.
This is about the ancients.
It's a little bit earlier.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The greatest change, 150, this is 152.
You know, and this, well, the illumination and the color of all things have changed.
We no longer understand altogether how the ancients experienced what was familiar and frequent.
For example, the day and waking.
Since the ancients believed in dreams, waking appeared in a different light.
The same goes for the whole of life, which is illumined by death and its significance.
For us, death means something quite different.
All experience shown differently because of God shown through them.
Now, this is the one moment of the argument in Truth and Lies as well, right?
But all decisions and perspectives on the remote future too, for they had oracles and secret portents and believed in prophecy.
And then just skipping all the way to the end of that, we have given things a new color.
We go on painting them continually.
But what do all our efforts to date avail when we hold them against the colored splendor of that old master, ancient humanity?
And it is that sense of a new color, like different colors.
Again, I just returned to this is a style.
This is to me like what there's a different disposition to one's day when one believes that gods are doing or not doing something.
The question is not, are there gods or are there not gods?
Like that's the least interesting question.
The question is, how does it change one's disposition to think that?
And then just diagnosing the different types of humanity, those who are running ahead versus those who are chasing behind versus those, you know, in terms of like there's all this stuff on fame and, you know, various other things like that where you're just like these little diagnostic nuggets of styles of life.
That's all I can think to call them.
Well, and that question of whether there are really gods or not being the least interesting question is the least interesting question for a couple of reasons.
A, it misses the point.
But B, it presumes a perspective that is something what we might want to call like realism or material realism where like the coloring has changed.
It's not different colors on the same object.
This is what we have to lean into Nietzsche's perspectivalism.
It's like the perspective is the ontology, is the production of the ontology or the production of the reality.
It's not an illumination of an already there.
Or for me, the next turn in that argument is the realist materialist position is just another color.
It's just another color.
Yeah.
It's not.
And if you take that seriously, it's like then it's just a way of living in the world, right?
In order to understand, like the question of is there a god or is there not a god, that is the same – that is – it doesn't sound like it, but that is the same question as what does it mean to – what does it mean to live with a belief in God?
Yeah.
Like is it – does it exist or does it not exist?
That's the same question.
Because you have to do away with the belief-reality, the belief-knowledge dualism.
Right, right.
Like no, the belief is every bit as important and every bit as reality-making as the knowledge.
Yeah, the question of is it – does it exist or does it not exist is a style question even though it sounds like an ontological question.
Well, and this is like – and you've taught me to do this, John, is always make the first move and then make the second move back on itself is to on the one hand say the material realist perspective is just an illusion.
It is just another perspective, right?
But then we have to not then fall into the exact same error that we're critiquing and then dismiss it and say, no, it is an active reality-making intervention.
Now, like the only error is it's from within itself to think that it is – it's the only one.
But the fact that it thinks itself as the only one is part of its force, is part of its reality.
It's part of it.
That's one of its attributes.
Yeah.
I have to remind myself of that in dealing with questions of religion all of the time when – like friends I have that are smart people that believe in God, like I have a very hard time with that.
I have a very hard time – like I have one very good friend who is a theologian and I have a very hard time not feeling like she's intellectually dishonest.
You know, that there's some fundamental, fundamental level that she's just like not willing to go there.
And it's like what extraordinary arrogance on my part, right, to not be able to hear her position as – I would say it this way.
It's an ethics.
It's always an ethics rather than an ontology, you know.
And I'm not trying to get into like the Levinas-Heidegger, you know.
But still, there is this sense of it's a way of living in the world.
And even if it wants to claim it's the true or the right one, that claim of truth or rightness is itself just a symptom of another way of living in the world.
But doesn't just Nietzsche solve that Heidegger-Levinas problem, which is to say is it ontology and then ethics or is it ethics and then ontology?
Nietzsche would seem to say is that the production of ontological reality is a matter of evaluation of value, which makes it ethics.
It has to be.
Yes, values.
Yes.
You know, life is will to power and nothing else.
I also don't think Nietzsche treats all styles the same.
You know, I mean, like the style of monotheism is obviously critiqued more so than the style of polytheism.
Yeah, yeah.
Monotheism in general leads to the reduction and sterilization of life, which is sort of the entire project is thrust against that.
Which is still a sign of its life.
Yeah.
Right.
It's still a sign of life.
Yeah, no, you're right.
Sure.
A life for a different type of –
Right, it's a health for a different type of life.
And so that's where it's like he's fascinated by Jesus in The Antichrist, for instance.
Like Jesus is an interesting character.
Christianity, on the other hand, Paul, on the other hand, you know what I mean?
Like it's a – you got to deal with each of these things differently.
Like religion isn't one thing, you know?
So, I mean, obviously, look at his fascination with the Greeks, you know?
I mean, it's – this is not anti-religion at all.
And it's always more – it's always more complex than that.
But it's always – it's always hard.
I have to remind myself in certain cases, and for me it is particularly theological ones, where I have to like say, hey, this isn't that person – this isn't that person's inability or incapacity to move past a dogmatism.
Right, it's in fact my dogmatism that sees that in them, right?
And it's very – for me it's very hard and requires will, a willful effort on my part to hear those things as something other than, well, she just believes in the dumb, you know, man in the sky.
As a general, I always have really uninteresting interpretations of religion.
I don't necessarily judge people, but I always treat it as some version of a coping mechanism.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
And I don't know how –
Same thing.
Yeah.
I don't know how else to really conceptualize.
I mean, I guess just another style.
Yeah.
But it's just –
But this is where I'll come back to what you were saying though, Nate, is that I've – one thing that I've started to do a little bit is less –
Think about it as an error that, you know, they're just – or as an intellectual sort of inability to go somewhere.
Dishonesty.
That's how I –
Dishonesty, yeah.
That – and less in terms of sort of like the, well, why can't you just reason yourself to point A to point B when it's so obviously there?
I turn to the coping mechanism thing, but this is also where, you know, I'll maintain a certain kind of hierarchy or something in styles of life or expressions of will in that this is one that just tends to attack and judge and destroy the world in order to carve out an impoverished version of life.
Transcendence.
It is.
I mean, it imports transcendence in like, you know, even though it is truly obviously very difficult to really think immanence, but nevertheless, like that – the ways in which the kind of – I don't know, at least to me, the default that transcendence is superiority.
Yeah.
Is I think the thing that I'm always just like – it's – I've been reading Nietzsche too long because to me when people talk about things beyond this world as constitutive elements of this world, I just always – I really do hear a hatred of life.
Like I really do hear a denigration of the phenomenal or something like that.
And what's even the most irritating – at the theological level, then at least when you're talking to the theologian, it becomes an object of play sometimes and you can mess around with it.
But – or at least you're sort of like operating within the intellectual.
But the way that it gets expressed in the everydayness of one's life and what I find like when someone's not interested in thinking the theological at all, there's an orientation to life as labor and toil and suffering and sin.
And that is – that's just sad to be around.
It's just sad to have the world transformed into that thing over and over again, which makes me think of – you know, this is one of the early Christian lines.
The dangerous – this is 130, a dangerous decision.
The Christian decision to find the world ugly and bad has made the world ugly and bad.
Right, right.
Which goes back to the very first aphorism you brought us to, Nate, is that the attribution of cause and effect or the interpretation itself, it's not a – whether it's true or false is the least interesting – it's the force of will, the sense, the evaluative strength with which it is turned into a world-producing machine.
I mean, in some ways, that's all I ever said to Boo Boo about Barad, right?
The willingness – the interpretation of the world as bad has made the world bad.
And it's like the interpretation of Barad as a – you know, an – you know, a material – a reductive materialist makes a reductive materialist, right?
Right.
And I do have that – I mean, this is the way in which, you know, I think I'm an idealist in this way because I really do believe that nothing is anything.
Yeah.
Necessarily, right?
Like, and that anything can be done.
Like, I really do believe in principle that one could, for instance – I remember Nealon and I used to talk about this years ago.
It's like, Hegel is not about negation at all.
That's just an epiphenomenal manifestation, right?
Like, that just seems incomprehensible to me, right, at this moment.
Or, like, Heidegger isn't actually interested in big B being.
You know, whatever.
You just take things that are just, like, super obvious that, of course, they're – and you're like, I believe there are ways of engaging this that that's not necessary.
You know?
Yeah.
I mean, and then part of that – I mean, just because you mentioned, Barad, just on that line – I was thinking about this the other day.
But that whole – most of that project was fueled by resentment.
Yeah, no, yeah.
Well, I mean, and I think – I guess it's good that I've realized that retroactively –
That's why we started this whole podcast.
Don't you remember?
Like, it was – I mean, I'm sure Nathaniel remembers this.
But after you did your – you defended your prospectus and I was like, this is one of the best prospectus – well, this is the best prospectus that I've ever read in my years.
And it just pisses me off because it's so – it's so reductive.
Like, it's so intent on proving something to be wrong and bad.
And, you know, that was the constant – like, that's what started this whole thing is, like, it could be cool.
So –
Yeah.
I guess I just – I don't blame myself at the time because I think that's what generated the material.
But ultimately, it's not what I'm interested in anymore is that orientation towards the tech.
Right.
Yeah.
And it's nothing to blame.
It's not to blame because it's like – you think of the irony of me saying – and it pissed me off, right?
That you were pissed off, right?
So, like, I'm – I mean, it's not like, oh, it's a stage and you grew out of it.
It's just a – it's just like at certain moments that disposition is oriented towards some kinds of things and other things become background or they become a different kind of color in relationship to it.
Or just take that growth model that you just dismissed, John, but now subtract the transcendence from it rather than, like, there's a natural progression and you went from one immature stage into another.
No, you – well, you did.
You went through – you went through a stage and that stage produced something unexpected that actually now allows you to reevaluate what came before.
It wasn't the natural next step, right?
Right.
Well, I never – I never – also never would have gotten to this orientation with Deleuze if I hadn't passed through that orientation abroad.
So, it points again to the importance of style like you're talking about because I don't agree – I don't disagree with the content of my arguments when I reread them.
I mean, I just – I chafe against the tone and the style of those interventions.
The smell.
Yeah.
Yeah, the smell of the intervention.
The smell, right.
Yeah.
They smell offensively Hegelian books.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's why you did this.
You wanted you and Nietzsche to have written offensively Hegelian books.
You did too.
Yeah.
That's good.
But it's – Nathaniel, I think, you know, it's such a good point to say.
What happens if you think of education not as the progressive heading towards the Platonic light at the end of the cave or whatever, but simply as a sort of differential movement along an economy of affect or whatever, right?
Like that to me is – and that is really I think how I think of it.
Like that's what we're doing.
We're not making people smarter.
We're shifting them into different potential dispositions which will alter the ways that they interact in the world and it will make – I mean that – and it is – it's growth in a sense.
But it's not – but it's not growth as like positive development.
It's just – it's transformational, you know.
I think that is what it means to make people smarter though.
Yeah, it's part of it for sure.
It's to have them – the smarter is that they've moved through different dispositional – that they have an array of different dispositions available to them.
That they've had to go through the work and the shifting of self in order to be able to go through those moves.
The problem is is that you can't say ahead of time what those things are going to be and that's the problem with –
So that's like saying – so that's like saying intelligence, smart, making people smarter.
Intelligence is really about the capacity to learn.
Yeah.
Not about the acquisition of a content or not about – you know – it's not about knowledge actually.
Yeah, it's not about knowledge or knowledge is at best – it's an instrumental side effect.
The secondary – it's a secondary content that's only important for the styles that it provokes.
Exactly, right?
You have to work with this.
Man, someone should write a book on that.
You have to work with it very carefully.
So this is the other thing is that that sort of – that trajectory that you're laying out seems kind of chaotic and meandering.
And it feels wishy-washy as opposed to the structure of a traditional model that says, you know, you start with A and then you go to B and then C and then out of the Platonic cave.
You progress to the next stage.
That's happening.
But that – but see – but that has a much harder time I think actually hanging together.
I think that falls subject to Zeno's paradox because it's like how do you ever accomplish stage one and then realize it and move transition into stage two?
There's a – there's – because you're dealing with static things called stages and the movement across them becomes problematic.
I think there's actually far more rigor and attentiveness to that thing that's supposedly meandering when you engage thoroughly rigorously with whatever it is.
And then whatever that stage is, which you cannot predict, I would wager to say is far more thoughtfully, rigorously, attentively attached to the previous stage than it could ever be if it was mapped out.
Why did you – why did you shake your head when I said that's Hegel?
Oh, I just mean because I don't – I don't always subscribe to the teleological – the simple teleological version of Hegel.
But isn't it – I mean isn't it – it's hard for me to understand how the Phenomenology is not progressive.
I mean it certainly is, but then it's weirdly – like I mean you know the story.
Like you get to the end and you're just back at the beginning.
Right.
Like everything – yeah.
I mean it's like none of – it's recursive.
So it's not simply point A to point B on a diagonal line.
Right.
It's like you think you're going up, but then once you actually reach the summit, you're just back at the beginning.
Right, right, right.
So I mean it's a little more complicated than just stages, but anyway.
My question is on back to this conversation is how do you resist this kind of dispositional attunement just becoming co-opted by the institution where it becomes something like a learning outcome, like rhetorical flexibility or like contextual awareness.
In case of what you'll say, yeah, metacritical, critical thinking or whatever and critical thinking becomes this –
Or maybe you don't – maybe you're not worried about it becoming – maybe it becoming co-opted is just part of the – you know what I mean?
Like how do you –
Whatever becomes co-optive, you know, it becomes co-opted and then it just becomes material to, you know, work with.
It becomes a bit of the calcified whatever to work with.
Right.
I'm just wondering if there's a way to put that on a syllabus where it's not simply another thing on a syllabus.
Yeah, see, I never – I feel like I – this is – that's in some ways at the heart of my teaching and yet it would never be on the syllabus.
It's only – and I also think it's only available to like small classes, by the way.
I do think that there are sort of constraints to it is that like what would that look like when you have 250 anonymous students?
I'm doing it for 250 asynchronous people.
Like and let me say I hang my hat for this whole like – the whole impetus behind this class is not that they're learning science fiction.
Like I mean I've – it's super clear that like we're not teaching – I'm not teaching you the great stuff.
I'm not even teaching you the good stuff.
Like I lead a lot of times with, hey, the movie you're going to watch this week is really bad.
You know, it's RoboCop, right?
Like it's not – this is not a good movie.
That doesn't, however, mean that we can't think in relationship to it.
So I hang my hat for this 200-person anonymous class on the vacuous phrase critical thinking.
Yeah.
Right?
Like and so I feel like I take that term and it – as much as within our circles it has problematic connotations like Casey's metacognitive.
In students, they're like, okay, that's a thing, right?
That's like, okay, so I'm going to learn critical thinking skills in this science fiction class.
I'm not really going to learn science fiction.
At least that's the sense that I get from their responses, which is like this class is teaching me to think outside of the box.
That's another such a phrase, right?
So to me I feel like the calcification of that process into a term just becomes a hook, right?
Becomes a tactic that one can use in order to produce dispositional – and here's the thing to me that's important in all of that.
Is it like, Bubu, this didn't have to happen for you.
It wasn't – you know, you weren't necessarily going to go through the Hegel phase to get to the Deleuze phase.
If you'd asked me a year ago if Bubu was going to be really interested in reading Deleuze, I'd have been like probably not.
He's going to be reading Zizek, you know?
But it didn't go that way, right, for any number of possible reasons or whatever else.
So that there's no – there isn't a kind of causality – I mean going back to the very first aphorism – or rather the causality is subsequently assigned differently now that you're reading Deleuze – you know, now that you've become interested in Deleuze differently.
You want to talk about strange ripple effects, my buddy in the department texts me and says, thanks to you and your podcast, I have to now go read The Logic of Sense because my new honors student wants to write on The Logic of Sense and whatever, and she's been listening to your podcast.
And now you have to come out and buy me beers and explain The Logic of Sense to me.
Oh, my God.
That's so great.
One of the best texts I've ever gotten in my life.
That's great.
I love it.
The impossible project of explaining The Logic of Sense.
Could I draw your attention to, like, 10-ish aphorisms here?
Just to sort of turn the conversation back to Nietzsche's perspectivalism, and what's increasingly I'm seeing here is a sort of a non-human rhetoric in sort of –
I think we've tried to do this several times, is to sort of more explicitly connect The Gay Science to rhetoric from, you know, like we're rhetorical theorists.
It's like, well, how is this operating?
And so much of it has sort of like we've focused on, you know, rhetoric's capacity to sort of configure the world or to appropriate the world or to express and mutate from a certain perspective.
And I think that there's an interesting, more explicitly non-human way that this is sort of – you can read it, say, between 159 and 167.
So 159 – I'll read 159 and 160.
They're very short.
Every virtue has its age.
Whoever is unyielding these days will often have pains of conscience because of his candor.
For unyieldingness and candor are virtues that belong to a different age.
And here on 160, dealing with virtues.
To a virtue, too, one can be undignified and fawning.
And so much of this, especially right after that, talking about egoism, talking about the desire for rest, talking about victory and defeat, on talking about happiness, on being in one's own company, on misanthropy.
It is, in some ways, like imagining these virtues not as qualities that a person possesses, but as far more constitutive, evaluative points that take up and make and shape the world, not just the human being.
And I think that that's important – I think it's important that – because we will often talk about will – I mean, we're not, you know – but just like there is a lot of niche of like you've got to do something different or there is a sense of change something, do something different.
And it implies a sense of agency.
You have a will.
Right, like there would be sort of like this humanist sense of agency.
But then there are all those other places where it's very, very clear that that agency is comprised already of a multiplicity of wills.
I mean, that's, I guess, in part why it's not – like the will, the decision to exert agency is itself a symptom of a certain way of living in a certain decision-making circumstance.
Right, so that it's not simply a question of a humanist subject with the capacity to act, to decide, and they've got an array of decisions.
It is much more like each particular conglomeration of situation and subject are going to allow for different capacities of the subject to respond in those circumstances, which to me makes it less a humanist sense of agency and much more of this, I don't know, like amorphous vitalist sense.
Like this is life acting, not people.
Yeah, right.
Or is it – I would just say just because life has such as – one can imagine life as an organism here, but it's more like this is difference acting, which means it's always multiplicity or configurations of differential multiplicity.
That's a better way of saying it than life, yes.
I agree with you.
I mean, you could articulate that through almost all of his concepts too, like fostering or enabling the overman or enabling the eternal return.
Yeah.
These are all functions – not just of enabling agency, like you said, in the humanist sense, but rearticulating and reformulating agency as a product of context and contextual relations.
Right.
As opposed to dominating context, which I guess would just be one form of humanist subjectivity.
But it doesn't make it any less agency.
I mean, that's the thing that has always appealed to me about Nietzsche is that you can use the humanist terminology still.
It's not like let's just throw out – there's no agency and we are sort of subjects of social forces or something like that.
It's like, no, do something.
Do something different.
But not everybody is capable of doing something different in every particular encounter.
Right.
Like, you know, you might come through from, you know, Boo Boo's progression, but it might go a different way.
That there is nothing, you know.
That's where it becomes – it becomes, for me, constantly this question of, I don't know, pedagogy.
Right.
Like, or education or learning.
I mean, what we were talking about earlier.
In fact, that's one of the ones that I really liked in here is 177.
Necessity of laughter for education.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
And this is one – I think this is one that I take deeply to heart.
Yeah.
And I think that's one of the things that makes me a weirdo within the context that I circulate professionally.
Seriously.
It also makes you an object of critique as well.
You don't take yourself – you don't take it seriously.
Absolutely.
It's the exact opposite.
But, I mean, yeah.
So, in Germany, higher men lack one great means of education, the laughter of higher men.
For in Germany, they don't laugh.
Right?
In other words – so, just to take that, like, the laughter of higher men is a means of education.
Mm-hmm.
Right?
And that, to me, is really interesting.
I mean, who says that?
Yeah.
Right?
Who says, like, okay, learning how to laugh.
Yeah.
Or learning from the laughter of others.
Not simply as derision.
Right?
So, that's the important part.
Because now go to aphorism 200 on laughter.
Laughter means to gloat.
But with a good conscience.
Good conscience.
Right.
Exactly.
It obviously changes everything.
And especially because I think, you know, 186, bad conscience, everything he does now is upright and orderly.
And still he has bad conscience.
For the extraordinary is his task.
That's cool stuff.
I mean, it is.
It's like – to me, it's like this is just – this is a book on pedagogy.
And here, I mean, I think what I like about laughter here so much is it's not – go back to the agents thing.
It's not that I decide to laugh.
It's not that I decide to laugh and now I'm going to master the art of laughing.
I was going to say that.
It's to be taken up in the flow of laughter.
That is not simply mine.
Right.
A certain sort of cosmic comedy.
You know, this 153 is like, from where shall I take this tragic solution?
Should I start considering a comic solution?
The comic solution.
Yeah.
Move from tragedy to comedy.
And that's the beginning of the pithy aphorisms section, right?
I mean, there has to be something there to the notion that, like you're saying, laughter is somewhat involuntary, right?
It's like interruption as opposed to – like you don't choose to laugh unless you do.
But like you also think about people who don't laugh as models for like what not to be.
Like Trump, you'll never see him laugh.
But also like we also take it as signs of wisdom or self-control or other things, right?
And there's – here there's – insofar as it feels like if I'm exerting or if I'm doing anything in my capacity to laugh, it's a practiced willingness or ability to be given over, to be taken up by the thing.
I mean, look, guys, the title of the book, right?
Freudic Wiesenschaft, right?
So it's joyful or gay, you know, learning, wisdom, whatever.
Like, I mean, that's – it is.
I feel like in most cases where you know you're in a learning environment, it's serious.
And there is a – there is an air of earnest, earnestness about it.
And this is to me the huge lesson of Nietzsche is like fuck those fuckers, you know?
Like that's not the only way.
Like that's just – that's not the only style, right?
That one can laugh at this.
And again, not just – not derisively.
It's schadenfreude but with a good conscience, right?
Like, oh, wow, it sucks to be them.
But also to be taken – yeah, to be taken through it.
Yeah.
Well, allowing yourself to be vulnerable to otherness or to – or however you want to term it.
I think that's something that I've reflected on as a process of my own writing that I think it's always been there.
But recently that's what's been giving me joy in the writing process is when you try to make a – when you try to consolidate a concept, which is kind of inevitable, you try to delineate a concept, put something in a box.
And then you realize it doesn't fit.
And then you try to shape it around and see if it fits in another context.
And it doesn't.
And then there's never an ultimate container for whatever you're trying to accomplish.
But that movement of dwelling in that indeterminacy, that's the joy of it.
But that really gets me thinking, Nate, in terms of that openness to the other because that's such a trope of a certain kind of left-leaning theory that is so incredibly – I think this is also in many ways a left-leaning theory or oftentimes left-friendly theory.
But there's such a – there's an important pivot there on that what kind of practiced openness to the other is being cultivated because the way that it so often gets rendered as a sort of undifferentiated openness, an openness without laughter, an openness of say like the camel, the desire to bear the otherness of the person,
to respect it, to affirm it, to recognize it, to whatever it is.
And then all of that then sort of gets laid through a certain sense of authenticity.
Am I being transparent?
Am I colonizing it?
Am I appropriating it?
Am I allowing it to shine through?
And then, you know, like then one's actions, one's appropriations become the condemnable thing, the damnable thing.
The – it becomes its own kind of nihilism to erase, to efface the self in the face of the difference of the other, to bear it, to recognize it.
And, you know, I think of those – the three metamorphoses in Zarathustra and from the camel who I think is part of that Kant joke that you were talking about,
with like all of Kant as being, you know, the camel of the people, to the lion, the critic, but to the child.
And think about the laughter of the child is the – it has to be that openness to the other, that practice vulnerability to the other is transformative of other and self.
It's not – it's not an undifferentiated portal or opening wherein the integrity of the essence of the other is simply transported to me without intervention.
Right.
It's not separate from the mechanism of conceptuality or cognition.
It's part of it.
So it's like even if you're valuing or preferencing or what's the word?
Like sort of – even if you're emphasizing that vulnerability to otherness, at least under Hegel's thinking or at least under my sort of quasi-Hegelian thinking,
you also have that cutting motion, right?
Like it's always a de-territorialization and a territorialization, right?
The simultaneity of that.
I find so much – I find so much alterity ethics to whether it – even when it tries to circumvent it, to begin with I and other, right?
Even when it's sort of like, you know, the you is this constitutive element of the I, it's still then sort of like rush over that.
And then now it's just about I and other and the capacity of violence between the two.
And that – like that just sets up, I think, a politics and an ethics of – well, they're just not really good outcomes to it other than self-annihilation.
Yeah.
And then it – a lot of it seems to be just fetishizing that indeterminacy in a kind of unproductive way too.
Where it's just like you don't really get anything out of that particular orientation.
At least I don't.
Except for the interminable, you know, quagmire of it.
Yeah.
I'm going to cheat.
I had to go to my old – the old version that has my notes that I've been reading for 20 years.
Because I couldn't find it.
Oh, boy.
And I'm cheating because I'm jumping into book four.
But it just, I think, really fits with what we're talking about here.
And it's aphorism number 324 in Media Vita.
And it is – I'll just read the first brief part.
No, life has not disappointed me.
On the contrary, I find it truer, more desirable, and mysterious every year.
Ever since the day when the great liberator came to me, the idea that life could be an experiment of the seeker for knowledge.
And not a duty, not a calamity, not a trickery.
And knowledge itself, let it be something else for others, for example, a bed to rest on, or the way to such a bed, a diversion, a form of leisure.
For me, it is a world of dangers and victories in which heroic feelings, too, find places to dance and play.
Life as a means to knowledge.
With this principle in one's heart, one can live not only boldly but even gaily, and laugh gaily, too.
And who knows how to laugh anyway and live well if he does not first know a good deal about war and victory.
So, I mean, this is to me that – that's that tone of like, hey, what happens if you start thinking that thinking is itself an action that life offers, right?
And not as something to understand or to comprehend or to – but as an experiment and as a risky –
As an intervention.
Like what you guys are talking about, the genuinely risky experiment where sense of self and identity and things like this,
These are all going to be at stake.
And it's like, oh, wow, that's the cool part.
That's not the thing that you want to –
Forstall.
Stiff arm.
Yeah, at all.
Like that's the thing.
I mean, what a different ethos one has to learning in that sense to me.
And that's why I continually return to Nietzsche despite all of the – I reckon, you know, many problems and the many very smart people I know who are like, yeah, Nietzsche is this, that, you know.
And I'm just like, yeah, but he fucking laughs, you know.
Or he teaches us laughter as a way of living and thinking, right?
So the idea of – in that sense, it's like Deleuze makes a lot, and I think rightfully so, of the tragic, right?
Like the role of the tragic in Nietzsche.
But like there's something else there that's not simply – we couldn't simply call it the comic.
It's not just the comic as the other of the tragic, you know.
And that's to me like – that's the style thing that I feel like – Nietzsche offers that, frankly, I don't get anywhere.
I mean, Deleuze is the next closest thing to me, you know, of like let's have fun and make stuff.
I mean, I know that sounds so stupid when I say it like that, you know.
But – and it's risky because it's not a kid's, you know.
But think about the kind – when we're talking about laughter and joy here, think about the kind of desire that it presupposes.
Because it does not presuppose a desire that – organized around lack.
It is not a satiating.
It is not – it is – yeah, it is not an amelioration of a prior wound or, you know, the cessation of some kind of suffering or hurting.
It is the joy or the feeling of – it is simultaneously a pain and a joy of a rupturing or a bursting forth of a –
Well, it's just – it's like what Boo Boo was just describing a moment ago in terms of his own thinking, right, where like you try to contextualize it and it fails.
So there's a number of affective dispositions, you know, you can be like, fuck, I didn't get it.
Well, let me try it again.
Fuck, I didn't get it.
Like, you know, and we all know.
We all work like that sometimes, right?
Like that's not really right and let me try something else and that's not really right.
But the, you know, the move that you suggested there, Boo Boo, is to realize that, oh, it's the – it's the making of the series, the serial production of potential context and efforts to enclose that is the actual work, not the enclosure itself, right?
And so that's the point where you go, oh, life is an experiment.
Oh, thinking is an experiment.
Oh, it's not about trying to understand in the sense of finally – like I finally got it.
I got my line on this aphorism.
I've got the thing that I know about whatever the thinker is and now I can move on.
It's always about that sort of serial production of recontextualizations.
I was talking to my students about this the other day.
Like, do you know like an asymptotic relation where – like I guess in math, like you're getting closer and – like say this line is reality.
You never touch law of limits.
And yeah, and you're just getting closer and closer to reality.
So like if you're trying to – in psychoanalysis, there's this notion that if you specify your language about your own emotions, so instead of you just happy and sad, let's say you're grateful to be around your family.
So like you're getting more specific about your emotional intelligence and then that's supposed to lead to like better mental health.
But that logic is that if you get better at specifying your emotions, you're getting closer to the reality of your emotions.
When really, they're just always – like language and emotionality are always kind of both distant and the same thing.
Like there's not – the more facility you gain, the more sort of reality that you see that is simply an artifice that fails to get there.
So there's like a pain that coincides with the facility.
What happens when you think about say like the complication, nuance facility with language as only ever series of interventions that can't help but always intersect, that never correspond, never reflect, never true, false, go out the window.
But, you know, as – again, as points of intervention, never possible of failing.
Right.
It would just be like John's thing.
It's just different styles of engagement.
To say you're happy and to say you're – to specify it.
I mean those are not like – it wouldn't be a depth model.
It's just a different orientation towards your own emotional stages.
One wouldn't be truer than the other.
But they would have different modulations of intervention.
Of course.
Yeah.
But you wouldn't be – yeah, you wouldn't be progressively narrowing and contextualizing to the point of reaching the reality.
But see, but that's the thing is – so – but you're like – what that second version is is the joy of thinking and creating increased specification.
Yeah.
Not because it's getting closer to a point, but because of the joy of creating specification.
Right.
Like –
And they're also just –
The experiment of thinking.
You know, like it's – it's also – what are the – one's facility with the thing allows for more joy, allows for a greater surface area of affecting and being affected by others.
So, like one can still say, like, yeah, you know, cultivate a capacity to talk about emotions beyond happy, sad.
Yeah, do that.
But not because it more accurately reflects a depth or, you know, an underlying being.
But because it creates more opportunities or more points of contact for experimentation.
Yeah.
For that joy.
Right.
It's just not operating by a logic of truth, true and false, or depth.
Like you're not – specificity is not on the way to truth.
Right.
It's just –
Yeah, again, a different valence.
But you almost have to think about it in a physical register.
It's like when you're nuancing your language with something, you're just creating more points of contact, greater surface area, more modes of intervention or experimentation, none of which are predetermined to produce X, Y, or Z.
But, you know, more tends to lead to more.
Yeah.
But I just – yeah, we were having this conversation in class.
And I guess I was just thinking like – because people – even in my own writing, you tend to think complexity equals truth.
But it's just – again, it's just a phase shift in your approach toward a problematic.
It's not like a rival.
Yeah.
Yeah, at something.
But I do think that there is something – I do want to – like when you initially said this, Nathaniel, I was skeptical where you said it's increasing a surface area.
And I'm like, well, it would just be different rather than increasing.
But then I think that you might be right.
Like I think that it is actually increasing surface area.
Like I think that there is a way in which what that specificity – the desire to get it right produces a way of interacting which enables some – which enables something that's just not available if you're not concerned with getting it right.
So there's that sense in which the true and the false is in the service of increasing surface area.
Yeah.
Even though we all think the purpose of true and false is to reduce surface area by delineating.
Right?
Yeah.
It becomes one more mechanism by which – or it becomes one more mechanism by which of producing the nuance of producing – yeah, I agree.
Right.
Well, so then the kind of more – what you'd normally think of as a traditional scientific approach is still generative of complexity.
Yeah.
And in fact, it's extremely generative.
Right.
Of course.
Yeah.
But so would you – like it's not a critique then of that dynamic.
It's just a diagnosis.
The asymptotic is just – the asymptotic is not – the asymptotic is a symptom in a different – in Nathaniel's diagram of words and things that goes – that does that weird thing.
Like the asymptotic is a diagram.
It's just not the diagram.
It's just a part of.
But it's a tool.
It's a style of intervention that presumes itself –
Be more precise.
Be more – like be more precise.
Like I always think of it – you know, I never use the terminology of clarity in my writing classes.
I always use the terminology of precision because it is a question of cutting and, you know, delineating this thing from that thing.
And not to get it right necessarily but to create more available responses.
Yeah.
You know?
So if you just simply stick with happy and sad, you have fewer possible emotional states.
Yeah.
I mean they're –
We have as many emotional states as we have languages to produce them.
Yeah.
Right?
Although it's not the language that it produces, right?
Like so it's – we can't simply say, ah, it's a terminological thing.
The shift is just really quickly and I think it's pretty much on the same – in the same vein here.
But here's a word that gets stuck with me every once in a while and especially the etymology of it.
And it's sort of – the word suffer and especially through the sort of the phrase, I don't suffer fools, which always, you know, for a long time struck me as a strange way of using the word suffer.
Until, you know, you start diving into the etymology a little bit more and thinking of suffer as a – in the more generic sense as to experience or to undergo or to have –
Endure.
To develop –
To endure.
To have our kind of – yes, be subjected to.
And this is less about recovering a real, more authentic notion of suffer.
Although I think it is helpful to think of that etymology, say, like when Nietzsche talks about perceiving life as suffering and the Greeks of thinking life as suffering because it's a very different sense of suffering that I think that he's getting after there.
But it's more the trajectory of the etymology itself.
Like what does it tell us that that sense of suffering condenses itself into pain and suffering and the unpleasantness of life?
It just – and it really – it always comes to me the most strongly when I'm reading Nietzsche on Christianity or Nietzsche or like even that phrase that you just read from book four about thinking as a bed to rest on, as a forestallment, as a prevention of the suffering.
Like the – it's – to me that the trajectory of that etymology is Christian in so far as it condemns the world and suffering life as something that is evil and sinful that needs to be redeemed.
But then also it speaks to a consistent labor and effort and something I think generally but also we could just say sum it up with the term modernity or certainly like a technological orientation to modernity to – that sees our collective telos as reducing suffering.
Which is to reduce those points of contact, to reduce that – to reduce exposure.
To reduce exposure, right?
Because that's the sense in which like I've always thought the cogito, the dream of the cogito is like a fucking bubble boy, right?
Yeah.
Like I mean it's like let's have no outside – let's have no contact with the outside is the sort of like platonic to Cartesian ideal of subjectivity.
You know, and so anything that one is subject to is suffering in both senses, right?
It's just – it is an intrusion, an incursion, which doesn't have to – I mean that just means that to live is to suffer in the negative –
In the negative sense.
The common sense of negative sense.
Get through it with as little – with as little, like, violation as possible.
And I have to say, like, I live like that so much, right?
Like, I feel like in my own sort of emotional disposition towards, like, I find myself so much living in a kind of endurance, a camel mode of, like, get through it, get through this class, get through this semester, get through the situate, you know, like, get through, get through.
And those occasional times where you're like, oh, there's something other than getting through that's available here.
Yeah.
There's something other than endurance that's available here that lightens – I mean, that's what, you know, what I need Nietzsche for.
To give me that – to teach me that laughter, you know.
That connection, though, to the cogito just lit a huge light bulb for me, though, is thinking about the notion of the sovereign individual and in that sort of lineage of the sovereign of the cogito as a fortress unto oneself that is able to demarcate self from other and keep the other at bay.
Think about the sense of the sovereign that Nietzsche articulates at the beginning of book two of On Genealogy of Morality.
Genealogy of Morals.
Of Morals.
And here the sense of the sovereign is marked by their capacity to promise.
And it's a very interesting kind of consistency that is required by the sovereign in order to promise because there has to be a force of will that is able to carve oneself out to promise.
Predict the future.
Yeah, predict the future effectively.
But not just predict the future, to make the future in such a way.
Make the future happen the way that I say it's going to be.
That is going to happen.
I will be there at five o'clock.
Which means I'm going to, yes, not a predicting of the future.
I'm going to make the future like this.
And now think about the kind of exposure that that sovereign has to have to the world around them.
This cannot be bubble wrapping self-autonomy.
This has to be, and I will transform myself in a relationship to the world, to the other, in such a way that whatever else happens to me, I will be there at five o'clock.
I'll be there at five o'clock.
It'll be a different me maybe, but I'll be there.
Yeah.
That's a difference in the song.
But I will almost always, I always experience it.
I mean, for me, I mostly experience it as like an imposition.
Like, fuck, now I've got to control the world.
Yeah.
You know, now I've got to make this thing happen at five o'clock.
And even though, even if it's something that I might even enjoy, like I went to see a play last Friday night.
And the whole, all day long, I was like, oh, fuck, I've got to do that at six o'clock.
And I'm just going to a goddamn play, right?
Like, I mean, it's Sweeney Todd, the musical.
I mean, maybe that was part of it, but, you know.
But the whole day, I'm just like, oh, man, I'm going to have to do it.
Like, it's like an obligation.
And I know, I mean, I know like how lousy of a way that is to live, but I see that sense of like, oh, I got to go to Sweeney Todd on Friday night with, you know.
And just being, trying to figure out how to like, how to turn, how to turn your lenses so that it's like, I get to rather than I'm obligated to, you know.
But with the relationship to the promise, so it's one thing to, say, make Sweeney Todd or the time spent with John as the object of affirmation.
What happens when it's the promise that is the object of affirmation?
Meaning that the promise, the commitment to make the future becomes a differential to affirm and to take joy in.
Right.
Rather than an obligation.
Rather than something to fuck up or not fuck up.
Rather than something to err or sin against or commit.
Because now think about the good, bad, good, evil relationship.
As soon as that promise has been set, everything, from a certain perspective, everything is negatively related to it.
It becomes an entity that can be violated, that can be transgressed against.
What happens if it comes from the, rather than the good, evil perspective, but from the good, bad perspective?
It is an affirm, it is an expression of my, of will.
It is an expression of delight and a self-transforming expression of delight.
Yeah.
Right.
That's why I like, there was that aphorism in there of, like, someone who compliments you.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Makes themselves your equal.
Yes.
And I'm like, I love that.
I mean, I love that as a strategy for, like, for insulting someone is to compliment them.
Because then it's like, well, or makes themselves superior to you.
Like, because they have placed themselves in a position of judgment, it's like, hey, you did really great work on that.
Like, I just want to, you just want to go around just being like, that's such great stuff because I'm better than you.
Yeah.
What also makes the eventual insult way worse.
Like, if you're to, like, set someone up, like, really talk them up and then flip a switch and just see the light drain out of their face.
Well, I'll never forget, I'll never forget this, when Kristen Poirot, when she was faculty here and we went through, she was trying to get an essay published.
We went through several iterations of it that I sort of beat up, you know, each version.
And then we met after, like, the fourth time.
And she's like, so what did you think?
And I was like, I think it's really good.
I think you should send it out.
And she just looked at me and she's like, do you hate it?
I mean, you must.
And I'm like, no, no, no, no, no.
I think it's, I actually think it's good.
And she's like, you totally hate it, don't you?
You are completely dismissing me right now.
Or you didn't even read it.
No, no, no.
You didn't engage it.
You didn't engage it thoroughly enough to be my enemy.
Right.
To respect it.
Just because I thought it was good.
Like, I really wasn't.
I saw one of my students, I was telling her, one of the good writers I was talking about, and I kept telling her it was good.
But I had, like, one comment, basically for a revision, where I was like, this part is not good.
And she could not get past that one part.
Even when I was, like, affirming it, she was like, I don't care about any of that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was like, how do I express to her that this is actually a really accomplished paper?
None of it was getting through.
That's just a sign.
That's a sad child.
Can't do it.
Yeah, it's neurosis.
That's right.
But imagine, like, complimenting, say, like, Jacques Derrida in his writing.
Like, wow, Jackie D, this is amazing writing.
And he'd be like, fuck you.
You have no idea.
You are not.
Who do you think you are?
Yeah, who do you think you are?
Even having the capacity to judge my...
I really thought you made an interesting point in White Mythology.
Yeah, you blew my mind by saying X, Y, or Z.
You have no fucking right to compliment that.
You are not.
I would rather, yeah, yeah.
So you'd rather suspicion.
You'd rather, like, engaged suspicion.
No, no.
Well, it's because the, at least from the perspective of this aphorism, is that the capacity to compliment
presumes inequality.
It presumes a pureness, right?
So it requires a presumption from the point of judgment.
Yeah.
It's like when you get your teaching evaluation.
This is always the stupidest thing.
When you get your teaching evaluations at the end of the semester and they always say,
the professor really knew the subject well.
And it's like, who the fuck are you?
You would just say that.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, you're an 18-year-old.
I have.
Like, literally everyone knows the subject better than you.
So the fact that you think that you're in a position to judge the professor's knowledge
is just like...
What hubris, right?
The only thing you know about this subject is what I told you about it.
Is what I told you.
I'm psyched to do chapter four because the first aphorism of chapter four is specifically
written for Boo-Boo.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good.
It was.
It actually says to Boo-Boo.
To Boo-Boo.
St. Januaris?
Is that what we have?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is the...
St. Januaris.
So yeah, for the new year.
So this is, looking away shall be my only negation.
Thinking With.
Thinking.
Yeah, yeah.
You're going to feast on this one.
Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought.
That's what it is.
The internal structure of becoming.
As soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from the subject.